dies wiederum mal warm und willkommen zu
einem neuen drei cocktails und heute
wieder mit kelly und wann ihr es euch
alle gewünscht habe es nie wieder mal
wieder da ist hier eine mütze auf 750 gb
speicher kein video willkommen hier sind
wir sind ja in unserem schwitzigen
gesichtern kommt weil ich mir darüber
gegeben was vor der audio gemacht doch
schon mal voll ihr wissen was hier
abgeht ja wir machen heute 359 cocktail
und dafür brauchen wir eine zutat die
schon gesagt habe wir machen drei
cocktails mit jack ist auf jeden fall
zum ausdruck das muss drin sein bei
dieser form nicht ob ich spiele
informiert nach dem spiel sportlich kam
management wurde wohl aber könnte man
sagen dass dieser fortkommen ist dieser
blaue drink
was macht das aber wenn du was trinkst
erfordert schilt schild das heißt wenn
ich jemand an schießt bist du nicht so
schnell betont wir werden keinen job
schafft getrunken hast oder ins ruhr
das ist wie wenn wir dann unsere koffer
extrem und dass niemand an pacht und
seminaren zu schnell so schön dann sind
wir da nicht so schnell geworden
öffnet ja okay so hier muss man schon
mit ihnen einkaufen gehen zu edeka oder
supermarkt
[Musik]
noch lägen in amerika und haben zutaten
die käufer und sie erst mal vorstellen
wie nach alters- und erst jetzt sieht es
ist ob es ihm aus dass für sich und ich
bin sauer weil es um unseren einkauf
geht und jetzt diskutieren wir weiter
das ist aber keinen einer persönlichkeit
was tust du dein gehirn geschafft
magazins passion die waren deshalb schon
ein witz wenn wir können es gar nichts
mehr wird das könnte man das baut die
weg und laufen einfach dieses gar nicht
merken dass du nicht zugehört hass und
jetzt führen weiter konzentrieren müssen
bist du so wie man diesen eigenen
zuckerberg hat ja okay das kann dir
alles was du kannst sie und andere seite
auf
dann kann man hier eigentlich müsstest
du das jetzt ausgeschüttet hat zudem
alles für den gelten
da kann es mal ganz einfach nur hoch
[Musik]
haben wir haben im wald dieses wie
kannst du denn das glas nehmen
[Musik]
[Applaus]
das ist gerade alles haben sich heute
noch bestehen wollte ich erst morgen
seinen getreuen wir das letzte mal ja so
gerne oder das schmücken des angeklagten
gefolgt sound als wenn es so klingen gut
kocht er also bequem und klappt das
gleich nicht alles hat so rein also
vorsichtig so nicht das ist
[Musik]
was ist nicht manche radio silber bin
schon so fasziniert dass du so will sind
ordner dass du so was ein klein bisschen
was wegen supermacht gemacht habe am
nächsten tag alle anderen dass er
genommen damit ihr nach dem ab was die
anderen machen zucker cola trinken zu
fahren man nicht so viele mails wie du
jetzt auch wenn wir jetzt diesen gurken
rotz da rauszukriegen kennedy das wirst
du nie herauskriegen wir werden einfach
nur fett ein weg wurden
acht jahre so darf damit nicht
übertreiben
ja also ich bin jetzt fertig mit meinem
glas das vorbereitung auf meine
kollektion bank steht und fällt alles
erst einmal warten das hin was gesehen
hattest du denn damit gemacht dass sie
noch genauso gehen dass man dann fahre
ich bin so aufgeregt jetzt eine harte
aber entscheidend
sofort löschen
[Musik]
auf jeden fall gewürzgurken also man hat
uns drauf
[Musik]
ich hab mich hiermit gibt die nicht
ausräumen
also das 25 pence ich scheiß hier
es hält aus früchten nummer können wir
fertig sein mal bescheid kann nicht dein
ernst ich habe einfach nur gerade vor
mir das ist einfach keine nationalhymne
[Musik]
was nicht gerade die ganze flasche nach
eingeklebt warum sich dieses mal so
gefühlt so weit dahinter hinter und vor
den krassen schild bei der schau dir
hast du da noch irgendwas reingetan auf
seinem feld und bluetooth
apa da konnte man jetzt auch die
wohnzimmer
momentan ist es warum passiert das dass
sie zu bekennen dass der passieren leute
nicht so alles was man kauft muss man
auch bindungen ja das war eine kaputte
räder kommentar-regeln okay sei die
raiders hier wissen wo man noch
mitarbeiten muss nur trinken ist doof
das hier ist mein kleiner schilde und
dann machst du den kleinen für die auch
jetzt könnt ihr den effekt jetzt bist
mir leid
düsseldorf und dass nämlich der normale
schild frankens gibt es nämlich unten
blau und verläuft haben nach oben nach
lila wie gesagt immer gleichzeitig
einkalkulieren
du hast einen heftigen day morgen auf
jeden fall nahmen bei einem gerät lässt
die immobilie plastischen vereinbar dass
man wie kann man so tief sinken
vom letzten mal also ich hab mir gedacht
luca ist natürlich auf aktuell hast du
recht kann man auch aber ich bin dein
tod ist so was was man mit dem kopf so
ein bisschen gleichstellen kann man hier
die tequila orientiert mein plan war es
so
man nimmt jetzt ein bisschen bis das
klingt dann geschaut und danach das koks
heißt ja also erstmal die stadien genau
einfach so
und dann spielt man mit dem kubus als
namen
so etwas habe ich noch nie einen hilfe
nehmen das echt schwein gleicher meinung
das ist wirklich lecker so schrecklich
und jetzt jetzt kommt natürlich die
krönung die immer ihr seht schon dass es
hier bis pictures außerdem wenn man
trinkt fliegen so ein paar clips am
besten zu regnen die dialoge des
geschützten distrikt charkh break dass
man komplett geheilt und ich mich so ein
bisschen die beiden kleinen da ist man
komplett würzburger monieren tod das
hier ist ein autoreifen denn auf den
autoreifen kann man ja immer rumspringen
im spiel
außerdem gibt's jetzt auch golf
kassieren
warum sind hier kleine habe ich fast
nicht
[Musik]
außerdem sind hier kleine rote kleiner
profi koran ist der begriff die säulen
signal dass wir irgendwann so ein glas
so priel drin ich bin ja ja ja das schon
wirklich krasse klappt
das ist schon das solle auch belebend
glaub das ist schon sehr groß nein nein
nein also da konnte ich nichts weiß
das kann man auch leute jetzt fertig
natürlich wieder die allerwichtigste
frage wäre ja okay war meter gewonnen
[Musik]
moment
[Applaus]
[Musik]
gespart kelly barfuß und privatschulen
wie sagen wir mal möbel nämlich bei
moment und ich hab socken vom ersten zum
letzten mal dass sie das nächste mal
kommt er wieder weg im neuen track oder
euch doch mal kommen muss unsere
bewerbung schicken
bewerbungen müssen gucken gehen
ich muss sagen aber wir wussten nach
methode die ganze zeit informiert oder
gekostet das liegt nach menthol und
david sagen tschüss bis zum nächsten mal
schreiben kommentare welcher kosten für
euch gewonnen hat also vom optischen her
meiner ja auch nicht auch die 100 punkte
das mag ich hier schon zu können
und so